on this episode a legend stops by
you ask questions
this is
ask Gary B what's up everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and this is episode 2
1/2 of the askgaryvee show
and as we can tell we have a very very
very special guest I'm not sure how far
the four people that don't know who you
are you're gonna introduce yourself for
me from afar we're just getting to know
each other but from afar music and
political icon is where I put you my
friend Mike left why don't you want you
four make a little say hello to the
vaynernation before we get into India's
quite a nation how you doing my name is
Wyclef represent to 110 I used to do
this in the cafeteria all day back in
the days I used to listen the NWA you
don't know me man up front of Fugees
born in Haiti raised in Brooklyn New
York City then moved to New Jersey
Cara's natural that's what we do right
by the way I'm sure to tank this out
yeah yeah if I could naturally do that
I'd have seventeen point nine million
followers on Instagram that's incredible
to the women suppose office now what
when did you realize you had that
ability when did that first happen oh
just the ability of words yeah
man up you know being in a small village
coming from Haiti when did you come to
the u.s. ten years old ten yourself dude
and I tell my daughter like it's funny
right because she gets everything I'd be
like yeah yeah you know um you know your
dad was in Haiti and then she goes on
here go down again with the story that
he wrote a donkey and it was the same
story but I just read I look and I was
born in Belarus in the former Soviet
Union
we came here we were super poor like my
daughter just had a birthday and I
looked at my wife and I said she just
got more presents on this birthday that
I got in my life facts man I mean that's
just the way it is that's the way
there's India can you flow can you canoe
you want to rap out of why class do flow
let's go
that's not where you're going - all
right so why don't we start the show and
so I tweeted out some to let people know
you were coming so there's some
questions business questions music
questions I'm sure other questions let's
see where people went India Omar Omar
asks making connections is a huge part
of the music industry for somebody who
is starting out where do I start
oh man that's a good question I think
like it's a little more easier for you
or more than it was for me harder sound
there's thing called the [ __ ]
Internet yeah the Internet is key I mean
really for me we had to sit the Fugees
lady at the single do like 7000 and ours
sand this [ __ ] ain't gonna work like
rappers playing guitars and women
singing and rapping no no no that's too
much so with the internet you can
actually and you on your own audience
and you were going through that process
of trying to think that what like a
night that was happening in ninety one
two and three before four and five well
it seems like what it was ninety four
three four five when it happened going
like 93 94 T nah weird it is 1993 a
group shows up with an acoustic guitar
and we talk about we hit probably from
the hood and you have one girl and clap
grabs his guitar and other kids are
rocker and I start playing and turn and
Lauren starts to sing John Lennon
imagine then I go into a freestyle can
you imagine someone who's a towering
that time and they know do you know what
I mean so the beautiful thing about the
internet right here is that you get to
create your world and if you're if your
music or whatever you're doing is really
original it's going to find its key
audience because through the internet
we've learned it's a big universe right
so you got your crown I I completely
agree with him and I say this all the
time the best way to sell is for people
to come to you right and the fact that
there are things now like musically and
snapchat and Instagram and all the other
platforms we know the fact that you can
actually produce music put it on
soundcloud and actually serendipity walk
into [ __ ] because somebody heard it or
shared it and change your world and
that's just incredible like people
didn't have that opportunity there's so
there are so many dip
how many Fugees how many you know real
actually this I'm dying to ask you this
question how many very talented
musicians do you think did not get
discovered in the 50s 60s 70s 80s and
90s because there was just only so many
and our people they may be lived in
Memphis they may be live in Haiti they
may be lived in Belarus like in your
opinion do you believe that if you are
great it would have just happened
or do you think in the 50 60 70 80s and
90s a generation that we don't grow up
anymore there were actually real big
time talents that never got their
opportunity because they just didn't
have the luck of being in the right
place at the right time yeah but you
know what's funny about you said right
is you see the music of the 50s the 40s
the 60s the 70s was a different thing
because people wasn't worried about show
business breck people was more worried
about the music the music you see so
this is how we know of the loneliest
monk this is how we could go back to
muddy waters like Babli don't go bentley
it wasn't really about because think
about it now whenever we this generation
want inspiration as it produces and we
go I'm in the studio with Avicii okay
right and we sit in in winter this is in
Stockholm dark right yeah
so we're sitting there and you know and
we're talking about chords and
progressions and what's the reference we
go back to freaking like Ray Ray Charles
Georgia so it's like at the end of the
day I just think that we have to
understand that that the idea of the
Fugees was musicality it wasn't like oh
man we were about to do something to get
put on so people who we were man if you
listen to the first fuji album is called
blunted on reality the whole album start
off with a poem where a clue club plan
is trying to come and invade this
generation and we talked about we are
not going for that yeah so if you try to
be in the music business dissing huh
his message that you want to put out so
I think that the key to everything
whether if it's art whether if it's you
know you think of like a Picasso like
when you look at that piece but think of
Ostia when you look at a piece or just
think of Miles Davis [ __ ] boo like no
one's thinking about so the idea is we
have to think a thousand years from now
like is is this conversations going to
be relevant and I really think that
that's my king like with this generation
and that's the only thing that I tell
them I mind yo you're spinning out
you're spinning out hits every second
every second or musically my daughter's
singing a new song right yep the new one
is an issue up then and then she you
know and then she puts me on musically
she like I know dad you doing it wrong
come back again
so third take 30 and then what I notice
is like after 70 songs songs are playing
that's an Angeleno who's this artist
she's like I don't know she don't know
but she knows this song I think if we
can push more musicality to your point
because they are badass artists out
there they are the internet you know
what I mean and we just have to fold
only things don't you think these
platforms give musicality a better
chance because back to your point you
brought musicality and the human being
that was thinking business is like who
wants this black eye playing a guitar
and the girls sing like right that would
that's what stopped musicality and now
the open platforms
I actually think of musicality a real
opportunity yeah sexy black guy respect
yeah okay alright India let's move this
Alexander Alexander asks what are some
essential things to do and to avoid when
it comes to personal branding from my
standpoint the thing that you know it's
really you know so funny I make my
parallels I know you probably don't know
a lot about this backstory but I was in
the wine business and I came out made
YouTube videos when YouTube first came
out and I talked to people in
Springfield New Jersey not far blues
oranges in Springfield New Jersey in my
office I made videos just like this and
I talk to people about wine I told
people wine tasted like
whatchamacallit bars or like when you
open a racquetball case stuff that
nobody had ever done before
and there was no wine spectator or food
network that was going to put on this
guy that compared wine to the Iron Sheik
giving somebody in a camel clutch nobody
was going to put me on the Internet put
me on and I think the personal brand
thing is really no different than
musicality aka originality aka actually
having the chops I think so many of you
and funny you guys know my crew knows I
compared entrepreneurship right now to
rap and hip-hop because it's a genre
that is getting looked upon and all of a
sudden it's Fame and all this stuff and
you see a lot of fake entrepreneurs
that's the same thing as one-hit wonder
just following the melodies that or the
hooks at work and there's nothing there
I think the number one thing to building
a brand a personal brand the number one
to do is to be you 24/7 365 forever
never waver regardless you know money
and fame doesn't change you it exposes
you so oh its binary 1 & 0 be yourself
24/7 365 and the thing not to do is
alter that in any shape or form Thanks
fax you're you you're in hip-hop we call
that you just spit some bars I'm taking
now I'm good I'm good bar take that put
that quote card everywhere all right
let's move it oh video good job India
Haggai review hey why clarify you guys
doing thank you very much for taking my
question
my name is Brian rips I'm a musician an
entertainer from New York City for the
last ten years I've been making my
living writing songs and traveling the
country playing for people one of the
biggest lessons I've learned is how to
take no for an answer and press on I'm
curious to hear from both of you what
some of the biggest nose you've
encountered in your career are and how
you overcame them and moved on to
conquer them good question
oh that's very nice it wasn't well done
great gets hot glad to you know happy
that guys right now my you be all you
you're killing that guitar he's in New
York
oh yeah I think he said yeah yeah the go
do me a favor right now a big hit me at
okay we're gonna do this let's make this
big I wanted now you got a deal with
this no no listen the deal with this
with me all guys I love it do it do it
thing let's do this guy right when you
come see me in Jersey we come we come
chill don't wear may have grass and
heavy don't worry bring a wine I'm
bringing the wife so that's why listen
why don't we bring a homie in done let's
bring em in let's bring Brian in and we
could delay the jam session okay that'd
be cool so this is what I'm thinking are
made on the askgaryvee show but but but
to his to his question man I would say
the no factor is a motivation factor and
the thing about it is it goes back to
what you say so every day you constantly
have to prove yourself only because your
last type you're proving yourself to
yourself
always remember that because the day
that you wake up and you say man
I'm already good on piano I'm already
good on guitar I've done wrote 50 songs
I don't need to write anymore
that's the day you're finished finished
because the thing that keeps us as human
beings going is creativity the day that
we lose that we completely lose
ourselves so so to your point is it's
just about each one teach one and
constantly being inspired and whenever
someone told me no it was always a
motive
xu4 yes I couldn't agree more I mean you
know again so many of you watched my
contact only as good as your last bat
chip on the shoulder you know like I
would say that I'm wired I'm well I'm
curious how I know I'm surprised how
much I do want I liked sticking it to
the mark I'm very competitive do you
find yourself competitive you have to be
like naturally you know like to me I you
know I I've talked a lot about loving to
lose
I do like there's no for some reason
Savan you know this wouldn't we play
basketball in the morning like when i
lose i'm like i'm like weird I'm like I
like it like I have like this like
there's a feeling that I want to
motivate Smee so much I truly believe
that the thing that separates so many
people is people are scared of the know
and the loss there's they think it's a
scarlet letter and what that does is it
makes them not go you know I love the
way he said when I get knows I push
through for me for me my early childhood
to answer you directly because two guys
I like the philosopher I'll go right
into it my early childhood was probably
my biggest adversity I didn't have the
same adversity of like being a minority
or gender or things I made sure I didn't
have a whole lot of money but the big
thing that I had was I was getting D's
and F's so I was making $3,000 a weekend
selling baseball cards in the malls in
New Jersey and but I was getting DS and
FS as a 13 14 year old and everybody
thought it was a loser my teachers my
friend's parents because that's when
school was the game and so for me I like
the market the world was telling me I
wasn't good and everything inside of me
told me I was gonna be good I don't
think if I don't think you can win
unless you love yourself first and so I
think you're right about it being a
one-on-one game inside your own dome and
so for me my adversity was early on
because once I hit the market once my
entrepreneurial Flair came out my first
year of running my dad's business I grew
it substantially it was over before it
started so wow you know adversity cut
you know I think the thing that's most
interesting to me is if this company
doesn't do well next year if my next
five investments don't do well if my
next prediction is that you know blah
blah blah is gonna be huge and it isn't
well then I'm not as good anymore I'm
fascinated by the music industry three
four good albums in a row I
one bad album what I like it's amazing
you're just as good as your last at-bat
that's right I mean think about it I
mean in our business we say 10 million
mm-hmm is it championship ring right ok
so like so to be able to sell 10 million
a few times and to do it for different
people right yes not yourself
yes so because this is another thing ok
cool you can make money but can you make
other people money because the key is if
you can make other people money you
create social entrepreneurship that's
right from society that's right and then
so for me that's definitely part of so
for me in my business I remember I did
when we did this score I got scared
after we sold 10 million because I said
I said no disrespect to menudo no I'm
not dissing I love like I love him cuz
he watching it yeah mother but I was
like holy [ __ ] like we're a pop group
now is did so yeah Pat disappeared man
got an apartment on 66th Street and and
third and I was like in a small room and
I was like I have this thing called the
carnival and I was like I have to do
this thing now so it's artsy it's artsy
I have to do this thing and then from
there God landed me destiny job beyond
sanam pray for so I was like yo we love
carnival there's these four girls in the
hotel you know we need you to just go
see them and then then I went to this
hotel let me ask a question about the
hotel room did it make did it did was
that a moment where you just understand
immediate like did you immediately
understand Beyonce had real big-time
Talent
or was it did that develop like just for
you one man I mean some people I'm just
curious how sorry I'm I think I think
for me I have a net like Lauren as a kid
yeah 14 15 she's for me bored yeah
Maplewood right I'm pretty Libya right
so so I have I get this gift from the
church so it's like purely and the
church called me the choir director I
can find a singer two minutes out like
oh this is the single assembly
so definitely when I first saw Beyonce I
was like wow right what do I remember
about Beyonce the most I tell you and
she watches she know every thanks for
watching me yeah every every and this is
like this taking me back right so
Destiny's Child was opening up for me is
that right watch this but every time
Destiny's Child got off the stage and I
went on Beyonce was always on the side
watch out English oh now people be like
man why is she so invincible
she's so invincible because she's a
student of the game
she put in the work right so this is
another thing when we talk about right
so for me when I show up it's not about
what I'm doing I want to know what you
do it it's better right it's it's
actually what I do for a living is
actually only predicated on watching
what other people are doing to figure
out what they're gonna do next you know
what I'm gonna stick here and be selfish
for a second cuz it's the thing I like
the most just binary whoo you one man's
opinion there's one man
yeah who was the most talented person
you came across and who was the hardest
working person you've come across right
now so far in your journeys in your
industry in your industry
I'm just curious yeah just so far I'm
just real curious and I know like I'm
sure it's not what you think about every
day and it might not come that easy or
like as you do for me it's a setup
question okay so I know Carlos Santana
watching this right now of course Carlos
thank you a lot of people's is we do so
but I get packet you know it's this
right you know I mean Santana's right
you better save me um you put me on the
spot okay I know I'm putting you on the
spot cool and in person spurious is it
good you don't have to answer Bob real
no hilarious and actually I really other
artists how long a hard work one to be
honest everyone's nervous okay so it's
good for me the hardest working person
that I came across in my entire life
so far or have to be Michael Jackson hmm
because and then this is why I tell you
right so when you are working your like
moving at the speed of light but somehow
you aware on everything going on with
the culture and everything like you know
everything at real-time like because you
Michael man you like it Asia somewhere
so why are you calling me and then
you're like yo you know I was just
watching this TV and I was like who's
this guy you know gone to November you
know I think I'm being pranked and I
hate the first time Michael cause back
I'm like holy [ __ ] this [ __ ] Michael
Jackson and yo this guy scheduled
literally shows every every day somehow
finds time to land at Sony studio come
up the elevator come see me
sit down and that whole day changed my
life ever since that I just see music
totally different on the perception
because I'm like kill this Michael
Jackson and he's sitting there normally
and he's giving me the rhythms while
he's sitting there and I know the dude
is coming from a you know the flight has
to be super long he said that now he's
like yo this is I'm here to base
dis I'm here the drums with his whole
body and I'm like yo it's freaking
Michael man yo dude what'd I tell you
I'm trippin I'm trippin so for me I
would say the coolest is the coolest
thing about Michael man is it Sam so
then we in a room with two of us and
then he's like man you know your style
reminds me of you know we was younger
they took us to Jamaica there was a guy
used to smoke a lot of Bob Marley Oh
Peter Tosh
available so for me you know that that
was a diet that to me was huge it was
huge and then and then I was amazed by a
short time that I spent with Whitney
Houston yes she was insanely incredible
Jersey yep Jersey crew and man Whitney's
work ethics was crazy and I guess I was
lucky because when Clive Davis calls you
and he's like yo van I need a song for
with you stood there like our treasure
and then Whitney shows up I'm like I
know Whitney I know you your schedule
and what you're going through show up on
24/7 ready to what uh insane like it's
the first record then being recorded so
when you and they invention yourself
you're like no no that's really Whitney
The Bodyguard is done and she's showing
up as if this is the first record she's
about to recover because money and
success doesn't change you it exposes
facts it's just so real and there's the
last question was who do you think is
the greatest hustler in the music
industry get out of town see I felt it
yeah I were used laughing were you like
this is so weird this is great the flow
the flow the barse Wyclef what uh what
what excites you about - how old is your
daughter my daughter is 11 and what is
she about so musically she's all about
it she's about everything tech related
she listens like the audio yo she lives
in the phone and what kind of me told
anything
she's eclectic she's she's like clefts
daughter but anything that is relevant
yep she puts me up on it whether if it's
like from a DJ snake remix mm-hmm this
is insane - the musically and this is
our has to be adjusted yep - to dad
I don't know man you have to challenge
Jason Darrell Oh to a dance competition
champ so into it and I'm what about for
you what about for you what comes most
natural any of them Twitter Facebook
snapchat Instagram
well what's funny is to every social
media yeah it goes with your certain
lightness alright so for me the one that
naturally goes with me is the one that
can be instant at real time and I will
be Facebook mention alive the life you
love that yeah I love that because what
happens is sometimes you'll just go on
yeah it gives the Fed real time I'm all
about because sometimes you catching a
vibe and you want to give the fan that
exposure that they can only catch that
lightning at that second yep so for me
um
I guess like for for dj khaled it's
snapchat yeah my version is snapchat for
me is like Facebook mention I love it up
yep I love it
Indy a good show Wyclef I really
appreciate your so enjoyed I'll see you
at the studio 100 percent bars what kind
of wine do you drink um are you into it
yet am I gonna educate you well of
course I mean you could never stop
learning you know what I mean so I look
I look bad working on this guy knows
right right I look forward to being
educated you don't gotta be but but I'm
shout out to my Russian Jewish friends
and um when you're coming let me know
because I have a few wine boys okay that
are gonna show up with some things they
bought back from the cave okay I love it
we go we gonna need your opinion or some
stuff
every time we have a guest they get to
ask the vaynernation the question of the
day any question you want
we'll get hundreds of questions on
Facebook and and and YouTube answered
for you it could be anything about music
it could be what you're thinking about
could be absolutely anything all right
my question to the Vayner audience
elections coming up Oh
going big and Bernie started a movement
and clearly Bernie's not going to be the
candidate but Bernie's movement have
become so strong that it becomes part of
America youth moving forward movement so
my question for you
is how with the candidate that you
choose that you're going to continue
with the idea of free education the
different things that Bernie is talking
about are you still gonna be part of
activating your communities meaning your
makers your congressmen your statesmen
on this movement that have started and
who are you basically going to be voting
for and why Wycliffe wants a bloodbath
in the comment section I love this right
I appreciate a man you keep asking
questions we'll keep answering them
what's up guys hope you enjoyed the show
please do I get to link it up anywhere
is it like in here
or is it down boo is it in print or is
it in my video no it'll be down it's
here down to my left
like right here there's a button for
them to subscribe to my YouTube video
yeah it's a little buggy thing that's
right guys
click this that's right use that